- [Voiceover] What is the
solution to the equation above?
So we see to solve 4k.
So one thing that we could do,
well there's a couple of
ways that we could do it,
one way is we could multiply
both sides of this equation
times 4k minus three.
So let's just do that.
4k minus three.
It gets the 4k minus three
out of the denominator
because 4k minus three
divided by 4k minus three
is as long as we assume 4k
minus three isn't equal to zero,
that's just going to cancel
out and be equal to one.
And so this equation
is going to simplify to
4k minus three, times two
and we can actually distribute this two.
So this becomes two times 4k is 8k.
And then two times negative
three is negative six.
So 8k minus six is equal to,
well all we're left with is 11 over one,
or we could just write 11.
And so adding six to both sides,
could add six to both sides,
and so those add up to zero.
You're left with 8k is equal to 17.
Now we can just divide both sides by eight
and we get k is equal to
17 over eight.
k is equal to 17 over eight.